i want to talk about
social innovation
and social entrepreneurship
i happen to have triplets
they're little they're five years old
sometimes i tell people have triplets
they say really how many
here's a picture of the kids that sage
and anna-lysa and ryder
now
i also happen to be gay
being gay and fathering triplets is by
far the most socially innovative
socially entrepreneurial thing i have
ever done
the real social innovation i want to
talk about involves charity i want to
talk about how the things we've been
taught to think
about giving and about charity and about
the non-profit sector are actually
undermining the causes we love
and our profound yearning to change the
world
but before i do that i want to ask if we
even believe that the nonprofit sector
has any serious role to play in changing
the world
a lot of people say now that business
will lift up the developing economies
and social business will take care of
the rest
and i do believe that business will move
the great mass of humanity forward
but it always leaves behind that 10
percent or more that is most
disadvantaged or unlucky
and social business needs markets and
there are some issues for which you just
can't develop the kind of money measures
that you need for a market
i sit on the board of a center for the
developmentally disabled and these
people want laughter
and compassion and they want love
how do you monetize that
and that's where the nonprofit sector
and philanthropy come in philanthropy is
the market for love
it is the market for all those people
for whom there is no other market coming
and so if we really want like
buckminster fuller said a world that
works for everyone with no one and
nothing left out
then the non-profit sector has to be a
serious part of the conversation
but it doesn't seem to be working
why have our breast cancer charities not
come close to finding a cure for breast
cancer or our homeless charities not
come close to ending homelessness in any
major city
why has poverty remained stuck at 12
percent of the u.s population for 40
years
and the answer is these social problems
are massive in scale
our organizations are tiny up against
them and we have a belief system that
keeps them tiny
we have two rule books we have one for
the non-profit sector and one for the
rest of the economic world
it's an apartheid and it discriminates
against the for-profit sector in five
different areas the first being
compensation
so in the for-profit sector the more
value you produce the more money you can
make
but we don't like non-profits to use
money to incentivize people to produce
more in social service
we have a visceral reaction to the idea
that anyone would make very much money
helping other people
interesting that we don't have a
visceral reaction to the notion that
people would make a lot of money not
helping other people
you know you want to make 50 million
dollars selling violent video games to
kids go for it we'll put you on the
cover of wired magazine but you want to
make half a million dollars trying to
cure kids of malaria and you're
considered a
parasite yourself
and we think of this as our system of
ethics but what we don't realize is that
this system has a powerful side effect
which is it gives a really stark
mutually exclusive choice between doing
very well for yourself and your family
or
doing good for the world to the
brightest minds coming out of our best
universities and sends tens of thousands
of people who can make a huge difference
in the nonprofit sector marching every
year directly into the for-profit sector
because they're not willing to make that
kind of lifelong economic sacrifice
businessweek did a survey looked at the
compensation packages for mbas 10 years
out of business school
and the median compensation for our
stanford mba with bonus at the age of 38
was 400 000 dollars meanwhile for the
same year the average salary for the ceo
of a five million dollar plus medical
charity in the us was 232 000 and for a
hunger charity eighty four thousand
dollars
now there's no way you're going to get a
lot of people with four hundred thousand
dollar talent to make a three hundred
and sixteen thousand dollar sacrifice
every year to become the ceo of a hunger
charity
some people say well that's just because
those nba types are greedy
not necessarily they might be smart
it's cheaper for that person to donate a
hundred thousand dollars every year to
the hunger charity save fifty thousand
dollars on their taxes so still be
roughly two hundred seventy thousand
dollars a year ahead of the game
now be called a philanthropist because
they donated a hundred thousand dollars
to charity probably sit on the board of
the hunger charity indeed probably
supervise the poor sob who decided to
become the ceo of the hunger charity
and have a lifetime of this kind of
power and influence and popular praise
still ahead of them
the second area of discrimination is
advertising and marketing so we tell the
for-profit sector spend spend spend on
advertising until the last dollar no
longer produces a penny of value but we
don't like to see our donations spent on
advertising and charity our attitude is
well look if you can get the advertising
donated you know at four o'clock in the
morning i'm okay with that but i don't
want my donation spent on advertising i
wanted to go to the needy
as if the money invested in advertising
could not bring in dramatically greater
sums of money to serve the needy
in the 1990s my company created the long
distance aids ride bicycle journeys
and sixty mile long breast cancer three
day walks
and over the course of nine years we had
182 000 ordinary heroes participate and
they raised a total of 581
million dollars
they raised
they raised more money more quickly for
these causes than any events in history
all based on the idea that people are
weary of being asked to do the least
they can possibly do people are yearning
to measure the full distance of their
potential on behalf of the causes that
they care about deeply
but they have to be asked
we got that many people to participate
by buying full-page ads in the new york
times and the boston globe and prime
time radio and tv advertising do you
know how many people we would have
gotten if we put up flyers in the
laundromat
charitable giving has remained stuck in
the u.s at two percent of gdp ever since
we started measuring it in the 1970s
that's an important fact because it
tells us that in 40 years the nonprofit
sector has not been able to wrestle any
market share away from the for-profit
sector and if you think about it how
could one sector possibly take market
share away from another sector if it
isn't really allowed to market
if we tell the consumer brands you may
advertise all the benefits of your
product but we tell charities you cannot
advertise all the good that you do where
do we think the consumer dollars are
going to flow
the third area of discrimination is the
taking of risk in pursuit of new ideas
for generating revenue
so disney can make a new 200 million
dollar movie that flops and nobody calls
the attorney general
but you do a little one million dollar
community fundraiser for the poor and it
doesn't produce a 75 percent profit to
the cause in the first 12 months and
your character's called into question
so non-profits are really reluctant to
attempt any brave daring giant scale new
fundraising endeavors for fear that if
the thing fails their reputations will
be dragged through the mud well you and
i know when you prohibit failure you
kill innovation
if you kill innovation in fundraising
you can't raise more revenue if you
can't raise more revenue you can't grow
and if you can't grow you can't possibly
solve large social problems
the fourth area is time
so amazon went for six years without
returning any profit to investors and
people had patience
they knew that there was a long-term
objective down the line of building
market dominance but if a non-profit
organization ever had a dream of
building magnificent scale that required
that for six years no money was going to
go to the needy it was all going to be
invested in building this scale we would
expect a crucifixion
and the last area is profit itself so
the for-profit sector can pay people
profits in order to attract their
capital for their new ideas but you
can't pay profits in a non-profit sector
so the for-profit sector has a lock on
the multi-trillion dollar capital
markets and the non-profit sectors
starve for growth and risk and idea
capital
when you put those five things together
you can't use money to lure talent away
from the for-profit sector you can't
advertise on anywhere near the scale the
for-profit sector does for new customers
you can't take the kinds of risks in
pursuit of those customers that the
for-profit sector takes you don't have
the same amount of time to find them as
the for-profit sector and you don't have
a stock market with which to fund any of
this even if you could do it in the
first place and you've just put the
non-profit sector at an extreme
disadvantage to the for-profit sector on
every level
if we have any doubts about the effects
of this separate rule book this
statistic is sobering from 1970 to 2009
the number of non-profits that really
grew that crossed the 50 million dollar
annual revenue barrier is 144.
in the same time the number of
for-profits that crossed it is 46
so we're dealing with social problems
that are massive in scale and our
organizations can't generate any scale
all of the scale goes to coca-cola and
burger king
so why do we think this way
well like most fanatical dogma in
america these ideas come from old
puritan beliefs
the puritans came here for religious
reasons or so they said but they also
came here because they wanted to make a
lot of money
they were pious people but they were
also really aggressive capitalists and
they were accused of extreme forms of
profit-making tendencies compared to the
other colonists
but at the same time the puritans were
calvinous
so they were taught literally to hate
themselves they were taught that
self-interest was a raging sea that was
a sure path to eternal damnation
well this created a real problem for
these people right here they've come all
the way across the atlantic to make all
this money making all this money will
get you sent directly to hell
what were they to do about this
well charity became their answer it
became this economic sanctuary where
they could do penance for their
profit-making tendencies
at five cents on the dollar
so of course how could you make money in
charity if charity was your penance for
making money
financial incentive was exiled from the
realm of helping others so that it could
thrive in the area of making money for
yourself and in 400 years nothing has
intervened to say that's
counterproductive and that's unfair
now this ideology gets policed by this
one very dangerous question which is
what percentage of my donation goes to
the cause versus overhead
there are a lot of problems with this
question i'm going to just focus on two
first it makes us think that overhead is
a negative that it is somehow not part
of the cause
but it absolutely is especially if it's
being used for growth
now this idea that overhead is somehow
an enemy of the cause creates the second
much larger problem which is it forces
organizations to go without the overhead
things they really need to grow in the
interest of keeping overhead low
so we've all been taught that charities
should spend as little as possible on
overhead things like fundraising under
the theory that well the less money you
spend on fundraising the more money
there is available for the cause
well that's true if it's a depressing
world in which this pie cannot be made
any bigger
but if it's a logical world in which
investment in fundraising actually
raises more funds and makes the pie
bigger then we have it precisely
backwards and we should be investing
more money not less in fundraising
because fundraising is the one thing
that has the potential to multiply the
amount of money available for the cause
that we care about so deeply
i'll give you two examples we launched
the aids rides with an initial
investment of fifty thousand dollars in
risk capital
within nine years we had multiplied that
one thousand nine hundred eighty two
times into a hundred and eight million
dollars after all expenses for aid
services
we launched the breast cancer three days
with an initial investment of three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
risk capital
within just five years we had multiplied
that 554 times into 194 million dollars
after all expenses for breast cancer
research now if you were a
philanthropist really interested in
breast cancer what would make more sense
go out and find the most innovative
researcher in the world and give her
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
for research or give her fundraising
department to three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to multiply it into 194
million dollars for breast cancer
research
2002 was our most successful year ever
we netted for breast cancer alone that
year alone 71 million dollars after all
expenses
and then we went out of business
suddenly and traumatically
why well the short story is our sponsors
split on us they wanted to distance
themselves from us because we were being
crucified in the media for investing 40
of the gross in recruitment and customer
service and the magic of the experience
and there is no accounting terminology
to describe that kind of investment in
growth and in the future other than this
demonic label of overhead
so on one day
all 350 of our great employees
lost their jobs
because they were labeled overhead
our sponsor went and tried the events on
their own the overhead went up net
income for breast cancer research went
down by 84 percent or 60 million dollars
in one year
this is what happens when we confuse
morality with frugality
we've all been taught that the bake sale
with five percent overhead is morally
superior to the professional fundraising
enterprise with 40 overhead but we're
missing the most important piece of
information which is what is the actual
size of these pies
who cares if the bake sale only has five
percent overhead if it's tiny
what if the bake sale only netted 71
dollars for charity because it made no
investment in its scale and the
professional fundraising enterprise and
added 71 million dollars because it did
now which pie would we prefer and which
pie do we think people who are hungry
would prefer
here's how all of this impacts the big
picture
i said that charitable giving is two
percent of gdp in the united states
that's about 300 billion dollars a year
but
only about 20 of that or 60 billion
dollars goes to health and human
services causes the rest goes to
religion and higher education and
hospitals and that 60 billion dollars is
not nearly enough to tackle these
problems
but if we could move charitable giving
from two percent of gdp up just one step
just one step to three percent of gdp by
investing in that growth that would be
an extra 150 billion dollars a year in
contributions and if that money could go
disproportionately to health and human
services charities because those were
the ones we encouraged to invest in
their growth that would represent a
tripling of contributions to that sector
now we're talking scale now we're
talking the potential for real
but it's never going to happen by
forcing these organizations to lower
their horizons to the demoralizing
objective of keeping their overhead low
our generation does not want its epitaph
to read we kept charity overhead low
we wanted to read that we changed the
world and that part of the way we did
that was by changing the way we think
about these things
so the next time you're looking at a
charity don't ask about the rate of
their overhead
ask about the scale of their dreams
their apple google amazon scale dreams
how they measure their progress toward
those dreams and what resources they
need to make them come true
regardless of what the overhead is who
cares what the overhead is if these
problems are actually getting solved
if we can have that kind of generosity
a generosity of thought
then the nonprofit sector can play a
massive role in changing the world for
all those citizens
most desperately in need of it to change
and if that can be our generation's
enduring legacy
that we took responsibility
for the thinking that had been handed
down to us that we revisited it we
revised it and we reinvented the whole
way humanity thinks about changing
things forever for everyone
well i thought i would let the kids sum
up what that would be
that would be a real
social
innovation
thank you very much thank you
thank you